peu importe les enjeux, la semaine a toujours été
étouffée face à vous tuer tous
commis le péché capital vous avez été
pris qu'est-ce que c'est que l'école forme des résolveurs de
problèmes créatifs maîtriser les
arts mortels midmark est le nouveau rat
bienvenue à Kings Dominion pluie vérifier sur
la célébration  tu es au bas de
la chaîne alimentaire comme nous tu n'as pas de
représentant les gens pour te voir faible et ils viennent
vers toi chaque adversaire a une faiblesse
je suis prêt ouais tu aimes Maria hein tu ferais mieux de faire
attention il va te tuer  hé les gars
[Musique]
ces animaux dans la gentillesse comme témoin
plus sûr d'être une [ __ ] c'est un monde froid et cruel
vous ne pouvez pas survivre sans famille
[Musique]
même s'ils sont des menteurs et des meurtriers